how's it going everybody so we have some
pretty big news when it comes to
Avengers for today but first
congratulations to youtube user Dennis
coy for being the next winner of the
infinity war blu-ray giveaway email me
in the email in my description and we'll
get you your prize for the rest of you
don't worry I'm still doing the giveaway
still giving away copies of infinity war
and ant-man and the wasp on blu-ray as
well as some special edition posters and
all you have to do to enter for your
chance to win is subscribe to my channel
like this video and comment below with
your thoughts and your favorite
superhero also if you are trying to
avoid all spoilers for Avengers 4 you
should click away right now ok so not
too long ago we found out that
crossbones is coming back in Avengers 4
in some sort of a flashback well we
recently found out that another dead
character in the MCU is going to be
returning in Avengers 4 executive
producer Michael Grillo was at the
Austin Film Festival in which he
confirmed that we will see the return of
the ancient one he was talking about
reshoots for Avengers 4 when he said
when we got Tilda Swinton she was just a
one-day availability confirming that she
is in fact in Avengers 4 if you are
unfamiliar with who the ancient one is
please go watch Doctor Strange right now
and thank you thank you
ancient one for not only is she the
person that taught Doctor Strange the
mystic arts but she's also sorceress
supreme or at least she was when she was
alive a lot of people think that dr.
strange is now sorcerer supreme
he is not yet we know this because in
infinity war when he's talking to Thanos
he says he's the master of the mystic
arts he is a master of a sanctum but he
is not sorceress supreme yet there's a
lot of ways that the ancient one could
come back especially when you're dealing
with people who are learned in the
mystic arts they believe in many realms
dimensions and multiverses it's most
likely that she's in another multiverse
and what I think is most likely to
happen is that she'll probably make an
appearance in
so world it is widely believed and
heavily speculated that those who are
victim to Thanos a snap are now in Soul
world I'm guessing that dr. strange will
somehow communicate with the ancient one
in Soul world
she has vast knowledge on the Infinity
stones and the Dark Dimension so there
are many ways that she could come into
play in Avengers 4 but what do you all
think do you think she'll come into play
in the soul world or do you think she'll
appear somewhere else let me know in the
comments below and don't forget to
subscribe comment and like the video so
you can enter the giveaway and stay up
to date with everything related to
Avengers 4 as always thank you all so
much for watching Wolf Wolf
[Music]